Latest information
that are reaching our hearts
business,
television
and today we also have to look at our country.
Spain,
for example,
has reinforced to level 4
the anti-terrorism alert following the attacks in France
and in Belgium in the last hours.
Javi,
tell us more details about that.
Yes, Marta.
But for the moment
the Terrorist Assessment Table
convened by the Ministry of the Interior
has not raised the threat level to the maximum.
At that level 5
the decision is made,
however,
by the acting executive headed by Pedro,
after analyzing,
say from the inside,
the recent attacks in France,
in Belgium.
In 2nd of this serious crisis
generated by the terrorist attack of ever before.
and Israel's response in the Middle East
since last October 7,
are also valued
the possible consequences
that may arise from this conflict
in Spain and,
above all,
because of the interests of the moment
there are complementary measures
to reinforce this level 4 anti-terrorism alert
in Spain,
but it is not available
from the department of Grande Marlaska
to level 5,
emphasis on safety
especially
in the places where the concentration
Israeli population or interests can be pointed out.
At least what they say from the department.
From the security department,
this decision will be seen,
Will also be visible in 1
increased surveillance measures
on critical infrastructures
and at points considered particularly sensitive.
What an interior,
that's for sure!
At the moment,
he has not specified that
obvious matters of national security,
the alert level is high,
on the edge of the very high the maximum,
and the wear and tear is the same as that which has been applied in
dates
where there are large population concentrations
in the streets,
Holy week we are talking or Christmas.
At the moment
the Ministry of the Interior assures us that
that there is 1 strengthening of the Islamic State
after 1 period of weakness for